the gorgeous final trailer for Disney's
live-action Beauty and the Beast has
arrived
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to take a
look at some of the cool Easter eggs and
things you might have missed in the
trailer if you spotted anything else be
my guest and let me know in the comments
below near the start of the trailer we
see Belle teaching a young girl to read
and pointing to the page with a blue
bird on it the page says the blue bird
that flies over the dark wood which is a
nod to the blue birds that fly over the
wood at the very start of the animated
movie and also to the blue coloured bird
that appears during the song something
there when we hear that song in the
original film Belle is trying to bring
out the beasts gentler side by
encouraging him to feed the birds in his
garden at first they're all scared away
with the exception of a little blue bird
who jumps into his hands by the way if
you look closely at what Belle's wearing
as she teaches a young girl in the
trailer you'll notice that her cardigan
also has blue birds embroidered into the
pattern and just after this scene we
also see Belle walking down the village
street reading a book just like in the
original 1991 animation and no one
adhered to this trailer quite like
Gaston when we hear the words you are
the most gorgeous thing I've ever seen
and then we see that Gaston is actually
talking to himself admiring himself in a
mirror this is a clever and funny riff
on gas stones opening song and the
original animation where he sings the
line there is only she who is beautiful
as me while as Mari his reflection in a
silver tray later in the trailer we also
see a few more shots of Gaston in the
first he's standing beneath an
inscription that reads Gaston the hunter
which is a nod to the portrait of him in
the animated movie where he poses with a
gun however in this remake it looks like
gasps Don's weapon of choice may have
been changed to a sword rather than a
gun as this picture of him here shows
him posing with a sword and the words
Gaston the victory there's also a
slightly different setup for Belle's
father Maurice in this movie when we see
him taken prisoner by beast for picking
a white rose in the 1991 movie he was
captured after stumbling into the beasts
castle looking for a place to take
shelter this use of the white rose in
Disney's live-action movie looks like it
was inspired by the 1946 French film lab
le la bete by Jean Cocteau where Belle's
father is caught by the Beast when he
takes a road from the beasts garden and
when we see the Beast
now appear over Maurice and the ground
it's a call backs the same thing
happening to Maurice if he sits in a
chair in the beasts castle in the
animated feature in the trailer it looks
like Bell hits Lumiere over the head
with a small wooden stool after she is
shocked to see a talking candlestick
which reminds me of the scene where
Maurice dropped Lumiere after being
similarly scared in the 1991 film this
trailer also shows us a bit more of chip
and we get to see him do his bubbles
trick again just like he did when
Belle's first had a cup of tea in
Disney's animated movie just like the
original we see Belle flee the beasts
castle after he flies into a rage and
there she's escaping through the woods
she's also attacked by a pack of wolves
after the Beast comes to her aid and get
injured Belle goes to help him and says
you have to help me you have to stand is
it a subtle nod and acknowledgement of
the fact that the 1991 movie skips over
how Belle managed to lift the
unconscious and enormous Lea heavy beast
onto our horse alone the second part of
the trailer introduces the new version
of the original Oscar and Grammy
award-winning Beauty and the Beast songs
which begins with the line tale as old
as time and is now performed by ariana
grande and John Legend if you're
wondering why this is a duet when it's
just mrs. Potts who sings it in the
original movie well this is a pop
version which we'll play over the end
credits in the final film just like
Celine Dion and Peabo Bryson recorded a
Pop's us a song back in 1991 and as Emma
Thompson plays mrs. Potts in the new
movie will presumably hear her sing a
more traditional version of the song
during the film when beef shows bail his
library he mentioned that some of the
books are even in Greek this is likely a
reference to the origins of the beauty
in the beasts story in the French 18th
century tale Leadbelly la bete which
itself was influenced by the Greek myth
Cupid and Psyche later in the trailer we
also feed bells hand on a map of the
world a nice hint of how she wants much
more than this provincial life as she
sings in the 1991 film and it's also a
little shout-out to the globe we see in
the beasts library and in the bookshop
that Belle loves to visit in that film
too and there are more nostalgic call
back to the original 1991 animation as
the tale as old as time plays over the
trailer for example Belle and the Beast
pick up their bowls to eat there are
some fantastic shots of what we'll see
during the new be our guest song and
Gaston and the food sing and
once in what looks like will be a
spectacular scene in the tavern also
while it is more or less a recreation of
the same theme from Disney's original
movie where Belle sings her song there's
also a hills are alive with the sound of
music vibe to the circle shot of Belle
standing on a grassy hilltop overlooking
a creeping Vista and as a very nostalgic
moment when Belle curtsey to the Beast
just before they dance in the ballroom
you'll want to look carefully during
this scene as we get our first glimpse
of cadenza whose swaying gently in the
background cadenza is a grand piano and
a new character created for the
live-action adaptation he's played by
Stanley Tucci and is described as a
neurotic maestro a grand piano did
appear in the ballroom scene in the
first animation however it wasn't a live
character we also get some shots of what
looks like a ball going on in the castle
it's crispy showing us some of the
beasts back story before he was cursed
we know that Prince Addams mother and
father the king and queen have been cast
in this movie so we could get to see
some of what life was like in the castle
before the spell so what did you think
of the final trailer for the new Beauty
and the Beast movie and how do you think
it's going to compare to Disney's 1991
animation I'd love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video do please hit that thumbs up
button share and subscribe and you can
check out more of my Disney videos by
tapping or clicking right here thanks
for watching and see you next time if
you go a movie lovers